hey everybody its charlie you guys been
asking me all about Valyrian steel there
may be a missing sword that we found at
the end of last season without realizing
it just careful for spoilers for
everything that's happened on the show
so far if you're new to the channel I do
weekly Game of Thrones videos be sure to
subscribe to get everything and click
that Bell so you don't miss any of the
videos but most of you probably noticed
all the Valyrian swords that we've seen
on the show so far there was ice Ned
Stark's great sword which has since been
melted down into Oathkeeper which is
with Brienne in widow's wail which is
now with Jamie which was previously
stored at Casterly Rock
for Tommen when he was old enough to
wield it but because Tommen died and now
Jaime is the head of House Lannister
presumably at some point during the
season or before the season starts he
went back to Casterly Rock and got the
sword now he's wearing it because he's
at the head of the Lannister army all
season long
there's Longclaw which was given to Jon
by the old bear which is the ancestral
blade of house Mormon cannot wait to see
if surge or meets up with him at some
point and sees that he has his father's
blade Samwell stole hearts bein his
family's ancestral blade last season and
then there's the cat's-paws Valyrian
dagger which is now with Littlefinger it
actually started out being his dagger
and then somehow mysteriously wound up
in the possession of the cat's paw when
he went to assassinate bran during
season one but in all these promos it's
with Arya Stark so there's a lot of
theories about how she gets that dagger
because it's not something that
Littlefinger would give up freely there
are other very famous Valyrian swords
that are well documented in the books
like black fire the other Targaryen
ancestral blade but most of those have
been lost we haven't seen them on the TV
show there is one sword that we may have
seen pop up last season when Mira and
bran went to see the three-eyed Raven
the true name of the three-eyed Raven is
Brendan rivers he's actually a Targaryen
bastard who was bequeath dark sister one
of the other ancestral Targaryen blades
when he was still living in King's
Landing
he has many adventures he gets caught up
in the first Blackfyre rebellion he
fights for the crown he wound up losing
his eye but through that whole campaign
he wielded the dark sister blade so
eventually he rose to become hand of the
king they called him
bored bloodraven people mistrusted and
because of his abilities remember he was
a green seer so he had skin shifting
abilities he also had the ability to
glamour himself which is kind of what
Melisandre does when she uses the jewel
to make herself look very young
eventually Maester Aemon father make her
the first ended up dying leaving a
question of the succession a grey
council was called Maester Aemon was
offered the throne because he was next
in line but because he didn't want to
start another war of succession within
the Targaryen family
he took the black one of his brothers
was named king the new king immediately
ordered the execution of the Bloodraven
or gave him the choice to take the black
for the murder of one of the other
contenders for the throne one of the
black buyers who had been in exile they
had tried to make peace so this is Great
Council they offered them safe passage
but when the black fire arrived at
King's Landing they immediately beheaded
him so they blamed the Bloodraven for
that so that's why the Bloodraven took
the black he eventually rose to be Lord
Commander of the Nights Watch and then
within about 20 years of being at the
wall disappeared while ranging north of
the wall so if it wasn't clear the
Bloodraven and maester aemon
both took the black at the same time
they were at the wall together but the
Bloodraven was much older Amon was a
young man who had been studying to be a
maester at the Citadel the Bloodraven
had been serving his hand of the king at
the time so let you think about that for
a minute because maester aemon never
mentioned the Bloodraven or any of his
other relatives besides the ones that
actually ascended to the throne
you could always theory crap that
maester aemon knew the truth of jon
snow's heritage because the Bloodraven
knew he told it to brand but they wanted
to leave it to bran to reveal that to
Jon Snow that's almost like a completely
separate video but just a really
fascinating fact in the path of dark
sister from King's Landing up to the
wall so presumably he was in contact
with the children of the forest and
since what would be happening with the
night king coming back and started down
the path for preparing for brand to take
over and become the next three-eyed
raven what about that Valyrian sword
dark sister what happened to it after he
took the black very little is known
about it after the Bloodraven went to
the wall so presumably he took it to the
wall with him just like the old bear
took his Valyrian sword long cloth when
he took the black
he has it with him north of the wall
when he goes to live underneath the
weirwood and prepare for the coming of
brand so the last known resting place of
dark sister is beneath the weirwood in
what happens during episode 5 of season
6 bran accidentally comes into contact
with the night king he gets marked the
night king assaults the weirwood and as
they're rushing below leave yells at
meera grab a sword get run
[Music]
she blindly grabs an old sword that's
sitting nearby in a rush below and
that's the last you hear about it but
the thing is is the three-eyed Raven
never left that tree he's over 200 years
old so he hasn't gone anywhere he has no
need for a steel sword in the children
of the forest which have been tending to
his other needs don't wield swords
themselves either so even though you
have benjin cold hands that's ranging
around doing things for the three-eyed
Raven
he has his sword on him that is why we
think that Mira is wielding dark sister
and she just doesn't know that she has a
Valyrian sword but you understand why
it's important that she would have one
because she's brand's protector he's one
of the most important characters on the
show so if they're trying to escape from
White Walkers wouldn't you want the
person protecting the most important
person to have a weapon that would be
able to fight White Walkers and even
though she might have a piece of
obsidian on her having a Valyrian sword
is the next best thing and it just makes
sense that there'd be some funny twist
like oh this old sword that was just
sitting here just happens to be this
really famous artifact there aren't that
many visual representations of dark
sister but in all the ways that it's
described it has a very ornate palm the
hilt looks like this so it's a little
hard to tell from these shots but you
know how they change the dawn sword
Arthur Dayne wields from the books so in
the books it's a much larger sword on
the TV show he dual wield and because he
does that they actually shrunk it down
quite a bit so the hilt looks much
smaller is much less ornate than dawn is
described as being in the books
the only other easy way to identify
Valyrian steel is by the wavy pattern in
the metal you can see Dan Brienne sword
Oathkeeper you can see it in Jon Snow's
sword Longclaw so hopefully we'll get a
better look at this when there's south
of the wall not running for their lives
so we're getting to that point in the
series where everybody important is
starting to wheel Valyrian blades
Daenerys is finding all the deposits of
obsidian beneath dragon stone they're
really thick veins of dragonglass
so hopefully once someone explains to
Daenerys why it is they need to fight
the White Walkers they'll start getting
that out of there and turning it into
weapons well let me know in the comments
do you think that meera is wielding dark
sister do you think that that is what
that old blade was that she just picked
up but what will happen next is they'll
be new game
the next day or so leave all your
requests for bonus videos and what will
happen is I'll name the giveaway winner
when I post that new video so while you
wait for that you can click here to
rewatch the trailer and you can click
here for all the other season 7 videos
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight